I thought that when it got to the point
where someone like Colin Kaepernick
would kneel or the NFL would be forced
to have half of their football team be
women that's when you'd see a major
Revolt because regular people love
sports and all that but while sports did
play a big role with people being upset
it didn't go that far I should have made
the obvious prediction beer you screw it
dude's beer and they're gonna lose it
now you got a bunch of regular guys
being like why is my beer gay you know
and now they're asking that question and
it's spreading and the morality of it
still has to be considered here because
if you're Dylan Mulvaney right and you
look at your Tick Tock you're like oh
what's my analytics who am I reaching
who am I talking to who's my core
audience I'll bet you're uh you know
I'll bet a lot of money right now that's
probably a lot of underage children and
then to say hey hey kids look at me
drink some beer have fun that's
ridiculous that's absolutely disgusting
that's something that should have been
called out here by the mainline Society
saying hey
um even even you know uh Anheuser-Busch
should have said who's the core audience
here